Breaking Bad's grand epilogue, El Camino,
is full of references to the beloved show
that preceded it, some more obvious than others.
If you were too busy freaking out that you
finally got more Breaking Bad, here are some
small details in El Camino you may have missed.
Beginning in the second season of Breaking
Bad, Walt and Jesse were frequently aided
and abetted in their illegal misdeeds by crooked
lawyer Saul Goodman, who operated out of an
unassuming office located in an Albuquerque
strip mall.
At the end of the series, Saul abandoned his
legal practice and ran for his life, starting
over with a new identity in Nebraska.
If you look closely, there is a brief callback
to Saul early on in El Camino, during the
night Jesse spends crashing at Skinny Pete's
house.
In a series of brief time-lapse shots showing
the sun rising over Albuquerque, we're treated
to three shots of different locations in the
city.
The second shows a nondescript strip mall,
but if it looks familiar, there's a reason
for that.
One of the businesses shown is Duke City Sports
Bar, which resides in the same location that
used to house Saul Goodman & Associates.
Gus Fring is long dead by the time El Camino
rolls around, successfully killed off by Walt
in Season 4.
While several other characters who perished
over the course of Breaking Bad still managed
to make an appearance in El Camino, Gus is
not among them.
However, there is a blink-and-you'll-miss-it
nod to the show's greatest antagonist in the
same early morning sequence when we glimpse
Duke City Sports Bar.
Right after the camera reveals the new business
occupying Saul's former office space, it shows
a fast food restaurant named "Twisters."
Twisters is in fact a real-life restaurant
in Albuquerque, which provided both the interior
and exterior shots for Los Pollos Hermanos
in Breaking Bad.
In El Camino, it would seem that the fictional
restaurant has since morphed into its real-life
counterpart.
"We take pride in everything that we do!"
One of the pivotal moments in Breaking Bad
occurred in the first half of season five,
on the heels of Walt and Jesse's successful
train heist, which they carried out with Todd's
help.
While they were still riding high from the
robbery, things took a sharp turn when they
crossed paths with a young boy who'd been
out riding his bike in the desert and just
happened to come across the criminal trio.
Although the child hadn't seen them commit
a crime, Todd still shot and killed him over
Jesse's frantic protests, later arguing that
no one was supposed to know that they'd been
in the desert at all.
How does this connect to El Camino?
It's subtle, but before the boy was killed,
he came across a tarantula, which he scooped
up in a glass jar, presumably to keep as a
pet.
In El Camino, Jesse sees that Todd has a pet
tarantula, perhaps the very same tarantula,
which he keeps in a desert-like terrarium
in his room.
When he returns after Todd's death, a saddened
Jesse feeds the tarantula, no doubt thinking
of the child he was unable to save.
Throughout the five seasons of Breaking Bad,
characters repeatedly hid things in places
where they hoped no one else would ever find
them.
Stashing stuff in creative places only to
later have to move them or risk someone else
finding them was a recurring motif of the
show, so it was only fitting that El Camino
includes its own riff on the familiar theme
when Jesse rips apart Todd's apartment in
search of his drug money after Todd moves
it out of his World Book encyclopedias.
One of the first places Jesse looks is under
Todd's kitchen sink.
The location should be a familiar hiding place
for eagle-eyed Breaking Bad fans, since that's
where Jesse hid his stash of meth in season
two's frantic "Mandala".
Of course, the meticulous Todd had been a
little more inventive than Jesse and had actually
hidden his cash in the door of his refrigerator,
but Jesse's beeline for the sink was most
certainly a callback to the earlier days of
the show.
Before Todd was a drug dealer and casual murderer,
he was an exterminator working for Vamonos
Pest.
While Vamonos Pest was a legitimate pest control
company, its crew would often supplement their
income by stealing from the houses they were
fumigating, or granting access to other criminals
for a price.
Vamonos was eventually purchased by Walt,
Jesse, and Mike as a front for their meth
cooking operation, and as a result, Todd became
increasingly entrenched in their business
before turning antagonist.
El Camino includes a subtle nod to Todd's
pre-Breaking Bad profession in the scene where
the two Kandy Welding Company employees search
his apartment for his money, pretending to
be police officers.
When Casey walks into Todd's bedroom, which
Jesse had utterly destroyed in his frantic
search for Todd's cash, Todd's Vamonos Pest
uniform can be seen in the foreground of the
shot, although the logo is only half visible.
It's a stark reminder of how disastrous Heisenberg's
partnership with Vamonos Pest ultimately proved
to be, with Todd, Walt, and Mike all winding
up dead, and Jesse fleeing to Alaska.
When Jesse realizes he's $1,800 short of what
he needs to start a new life, he decides that
instead of asking his friends or robbing his
parents, he'll instead go to the men of Kandy
Welding Company, who are as deep into illegal
activity as Jesse ever was.
Earlier, Jesse convinced Neil Kandy to split
Todd's money with him three ways, knowing
that they both had a vested interest in not
doing anything that would draw the attention
of the police.
Although Jesse only asks for $1,800; a relatively
small amount, considering Neil's take was
likely somewhere in the vicinity of a quarter
of a million dollars; a coked-up Neil suggests
that the two of them decide who gets the money
in a winner-take-all old-fashioned shootout.
"Like the Wild West?"
"Yeah.
Like the Wild West."
Breaking Bad has often been referred to as
a modern-day Western, and this scene could
easily be a nod to the genre that inspired
much of the aesthetic of the series.
However, the "Wild West" reference may be
doing double duty, possibly also winking at
Aaron Paul's upcoming role on HBO's Westworld,
another show that offers a post-modern take
on classic Western tropes.
Although little is known about Paul's role
on the sci-fi series as of the making of this
video, his mention of the "Wild West" in El
Camino may not only be tipping his hat toward
the show he's leaving behind, but also the
one yet to come.
"Dude, you're on fire."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.